well right now lawmakers in carson city
are scrambling to finish their
legislative session with just
one day left the big items remaining
changes how do we how
changes on how we vote rather a public
health insurance option
and taxes on the mining industry eight
news now is your only local station on
the ground at the state capitol
the i-team's david charns is there live
with the latest
david hayler sasha you could say it is
the rush to the end here in
carson city lawmakers have until
tomorrow to pass everything that they
want before the next session
it's not for another two years and they
have to do everything by 12
a.m on tuesday so there is a lot to get
to but the big
topic here is mining specifically taxing
the mining industry it's an industry
that
that brings in a lot of money every year
we're talking billions of dollars
democrats have worked for years to get
something like this passed
this proposal would tax the mining
industry bringing in an estimated 80
million dollars to the state budget a
year specifically to go toward schools
and education
a lot of discussion about mining came
about with the pandemic
nevada when our economy is based on all
gaming
we don't survive and so we have to
diversify our economy we have to do more
with revenue
and we need to have a broader
conversation about revenue this is the
beginning of that conversation this is a
good start
now the chair of the nevada republican
party saying in a statement quote ab-495
much like any new tax introduced in
nevada is a clear violation of the
party's platform and an unnecessary
solution to a problem brought by the
democrats inability
to lead and govern now this proposal
they're talking about is actually a
compromise between lawmakers here
the governors and even the mining
industry they're actually for this
proposal that's someone sort of
going around the hallways here today a
very casual sunday the day before
memorial day but of course
lawmakers will be working on the holiday
we'll talk a lot
about all the issues that they have to
work on today and tomorrow including one
that
lawmakers say would bring jobs back to
the strip coming up next at 6. for now
live in carson city i'm david charns 8
news now